a classic snack to bridge the gap it
comes with optional onions and a served
sliced or whole some like it with fries
others with a bun a must a legend sign
it again they're very good after a long
shopping trip you need to refuel coley
would advise hit the spot Cory boys
always they don't make a meal of things
at khuddam 195 on the famous Berlin
Street of that name quick as you like
the sausages sliced spiced and doused in
ketchup or a special hot sauce we fry
them turning them continually the oil
they are fried in has to be changed
daily which all we use is a secret
everyone uses their own variety Brillion
is home to some 500 snack bars this one
in the city's Kreuzberg district serves
some 600,000 curry boast annually these
specimens are made of pork and come with
or without sausage skin the wrinkly
skinless variety is a brilliant
specialty Berlin never sleeps we're
always busy whether it's workers or
tourists at weekends my colleagues serve
until 5:00 or 6:00 in the morning even
when we're cleaning up people come in
and say what are you closing already
holiday so why not
pata Hoover is said to have invented the
curried sausage that has become
associated with Berlin visitors to the
quarry Voss museum can learn about her
and the spicy mix she patented in 1959
the wrist she created the currywurst in
September of 1949 she called the stand
where she sold her sausages the first
currywurst cook shop in the world
that's the story that has gone down as
legend here in Berlin she stanky she
embedding of the singer's act but not
everyone agrees
both the Ruhr region and hamburg also
claim to be the birthplace of the prized
sausage the upmarket Hamburg snack bar
curry queen uses buffalo meat and
Japanese beef and has an entry in the
2014 go mio gourmet guide they serve
them with green salad or homemade potato
salad and the customers can choose their
curry of choice to top it off we have
seven different curries from very mild
to very hot but we're more interested in
the aroma than and how hot they are we
have one with hibiscus flowers which is
purple it's really good and children
like it because it's mild and it looks
cute we also have one with vanilla one
with lemongrass plus a classics garlic
ginger curry back in Berlin turn up cos
in Prenzlauer Berg started selling car
Evo's back in 1960 even Liza Minnelli
dined out of a spicy delight from a
paper plate
so else I'd have said no to Mothma
during the East German era we only had
access to tomato puree so we bought a
bottle of ketchup from West Berlin and
kept on experimenting until we were able
to match the taste and the recipe has
stood the test of time
[Music]
the quarry Voltaire is really good I
like German food I like it really spicy
the meter Konopka this great and that's
really important for coring forest it
tastes great but weather in Berlin
Hamburg or the Ruhr region the quarry
Voss is without a doubt one of Germany's
culinary classics